which whole numbers will make this
statement true and we have the statement
here where we have some brackets are
less than seven so we just have to
figure out which whole numbers that if
we put them here are really less than
seven so let's draw a number line let's
go up to seven when we talk about whole
numbers we're talking about the
non-negative numbers or the numbers that
start at 0 and they aren't fractions so
let me draw them on a number line so
let's say we have this number line right
here
we'll start at zero you could go below
zero there are negative numbers but
we're not going to concern ourselves
with them right now so you have 0
7 i'll go up a little bit eight
nine now we want all of the numbers that
are less than seven that's what that
means we could write it like this
question mark is less than seven and
what would satisfy question mark and the
the hardest thing about these greater
than or less than is remembering what
the symbol means we have the smaller
side pointing to the question mark so
that is a smaller number the and we have
the larger side of the symbol pointing
to the seven so seven is going to be the
larger of the two numbers so what
numbers satisfy that well anything below
seven any whole number below seven so if
we look at seven on the lumbar line what
are all of the whole numbers below seven
that are less than seven well we have a
six
we have five we have 4
1 or 0. so you could put any of these
numbers here and the statement would be
true you could write 0 is less than 7.
that's true you could write 3 is less
than 7 that's true you could write 6 is
less than 7
and that would be true you could not
write that 8 is less than 7 so 8 would
not satisfy this this is not
this is not true
this is not true so we cannot write that
8 is greater than 7.